peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc insu réalité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de cette émission du mardi 16
novembre à à la une la crise migratoire
à la frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie
des affrontements entre migrants et
policiers polonais ont éclaté
aujourd'hui jets de pierre contre gaz
lacrymogènes la russie juge
inacceptables recours à la force par
varsovie contre ces réfugiés qui tentent
de rejoindre l'europe environ 4000
migrants campe actuellement dans le
froid et des conditions qui se dégrade
de jour en jour on retrouvera sur place
notre envoyé spécial david kelly fin
plus proche de nous en france un
campement d'environ un millier de
migrants démantelé à grande synthe dans
le nord une évacuation menée par les
forces de l'ordre à la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur opération menée
sur fond de tensions entre paris et
londres autour de la question migratoire
et au moment où le traitement réservé
aux exilés en france et pointé du doigt
maltraitant d'état dénonce un rapport
parlementaire alors selon vous la france
doit-elle l'exemple en matière de
gestion de l'immigration on attend vos
réactions sur le comté d g verte et
france et on en débattra avec nos
invités
quelle arme utilisée pour faire face à
une éventuelle cinquième vague de
contamination de kobe dans france on
tentera de répondre à cette question dès
21h pour gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement aucun confinement prévue
aujourd'hui ni de près ni de loin
pourtant les hospitalisations sont en
hausse d'un peu plus de 6 % et le taux
d'incidence augmente au dessus de 100
cas pour 100000 habitants
[Musique]
mons qu'on juge donc inacceptable le
recours à la force par la pologne contre
des migrants les forces de l'ordre
polonais ont fait usage aujourd'hui de
canons à eau et de gaz lacrymogène
varsovie cherche à repousser ces
milliers de personnes qui veulent
franchir sa frontière depuis la
biélorussie on retrouve notre envoyé
spécial david kelly phare en pologne
bonsoir david affrontements donc entre
migrants et policiers polonais la
situation devient on peut le dire
incontrôlable sur place
effectivement stéphanie le terrain
contre la baie et a très bien elle
choisit encore une fois à des images
transmises par les postes de gardes
frontières le gouvernement polonais
avait anticipé cette situation avait
prévu cette situation puisque en
l'espace d'un jour le nombre de migrants
à la frontière a pratiquement doublé en
est passé de 2000 à 4000 migrants a
selon les autorités locales sur tout le
long de cette frontière avec la
biélorussie
le gouvernement polonais a donc renforcé
sa présence militaire et ça a
complètement dégénéré comme on a pu voir
sur les images retransmises à part le
ministère de l'intérieur le ministère de
la défense et le ministère de
l'intérieur polonais l'afflux de
migrants devient incontrôlable et ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'au chaque paint de
brousse gear du côté des logos et bien
certains migrants ont commencé à jeter
des pierres en direction des forces
polonaises un policier a été grièvement
blessé dans les heurts un policier qui
était agrément blessé au crâne et à
partir de ce moment là les forces
polonaises ont répondu avec des tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes et des jets d'eau des
jets d'eau vous imaginez par des canons
à eau vous imaginez par ces températures
qui sont assez insupportable à vivre
pour pour ces migrants qui se masse de
plus en plus à cette frontière polonaise
et qui tentent de traverser tant bien
que mal la la frontière pour se rendre
en allemagne il y avait également des
individus qui se sont dirigés vers cette
frontière munis de buch voilà est-ce
qu'on a pu entendre en tout cas ait pu
voir sur ces images puisque comme je
vous le disais c'est une version des
faits avancée par le ministère de la
défense polonaise sur twitter mais de
notre côté pour nous les journalistes il
est toujours impossible de se rendre sur
ces zones elle dit d'état d'urgence
puisque on en a fait les frais hier avec
notre arrestation les journalistes ici
ne ne peuvent pas travailler de la
frontière polonaise ne peuvent pas faire
un état des lieux de ce qui se passe en
tout cas du côté polonais est ce qui ce
qui sait ce qui se passe également c'est
que 183 communes sont pour l'instant en
état d'urgence est fermé à ses
journalistes à une première depuis
1989 ce qui devrait se passer dans le
futur et bien selon les sources
policières et selon ce qu'on a pu
comprendre hier lors de notre
arrestation est bien c'est que des zones
spécifiques pour les médias vont être
mises en place à partir du mois de
décembre un mois de décembre particulier
pour le gouvernement polonais puisque
vous le savez c'est à partir de ce mois
qu'un mur va être érigé qui va commencer
en tout cas à être construit un tout du
long de la frontière avec la biélorussie
un mur qui devrait s'étendre sur 180 km
et qui devrait coûter 350 3,1 millions
d'euros une mesure qui est significative
de la tension palpable avec elle à
abidos russie en tout cas les tensions
ne comptent pas s apaiser un puisque de
plus en plus de migrants arrivent à
cette frontière avec la pologne dans
l'espoir de traverser le pays est
d'arriver jusqu'en allemagne pour rappel
également le ministère de l'intérieur a
envoyé des messages à tous les portables
étrangers qui se trouvent aux abords de
cette frontière avec des directives
toujours aussi claire ne tentez pas de
traverser la pologne pour aller en
allemagne épargner votre vie épargne et
votre santé en clair rentrée rester ou
rentrez chez vous voilà la situation en
tout cas de ce qu'on a pu entendre et
voir puisque je vous le rappelle nous
sommes à bialystok à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de la frontière avec la
biélorussie pour nous impossible
d'atteindre ces zones dites d'état à
d'urgence merci beaucoup david kelly
phare en direct de pologne avec les
images signées jordi demory et on vient
donc de l'entendre 1a crise migratoire
entre la pologne et la biélorussie qui
s'est mué en confrontation diplomatique
un dossier qui inquiète bien au delà des
deux pays moscou comme paris appelle à
la désescalade adrien fonteneau
face à ces enfants ces femmes ces
milliers de migrants à massés à la
frontière biélorusse l'armée polonaise
avait déjà usé de la force mais ce mardi
les moyens utilisés ont provoqué
l'indignation
le comportement de la partie polonaise
est absolument inacceptable
je pense que le gaz lacrymogènes les
canons à eau les tire au dessus des
têtes des migrants direction de la
biélorussie tout cela reflète
l'intention de cacher ses actions
ils ne peuvent pas ne pas comprendre
qu'ils sont en train de violer toutes
les normes imaginables du droit
international humanitaire et d'autres
accords de la communauté internationale
bien sûr qu'il le comprenne
une condamnation qui reste néanmoins
isolé dans ce conflit migratoire entamé
depuis plusieurs semaines si la police
polonaise fait état d'un fonctionnaire
grièvement blessé dans les affrontements
les agissements de son armée ne sont pas
toujours pointée du doigt
l'europe est unie depuis le début de
cette crise évidemment cette escalade me
désole la france ce qu'elle dit l'europe
ce qu'elle dit c'est qu'on doit faire
respecter nos frontières ce qu'elle dit
c'est qu'elle est en solidarité avec les
pays confrontés à cette situation
ce que je dis c'est que je n'ai pas de
leçon à donner à des pays qui sont
confrontés à cette situation pour son
premier ministre jean castex la
biélorussie instrumentalise de manière
inhumaine les flux migratoires et face
aux tensions grandissantes dans un
conflit qui dépasse la simple frontière
avec la pologne
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko appel à l'apaisement après
un entretien avec la chancelière
allemande angela merkel nous sommes
parvenus à un consensus selon lequel
personne n'a besoin d' escalade ni
l'union européenne ni la biélorussie et
nous ne pouvons pas permettre qu'une
escalade peu importe à quel point
quelques uns le souhaitent de vienne une
confrontation ardente
malgré l'accès limité aux produits de
première nécessité le froid et surtout
la construction d'un mur annoncées par
le gouvernement polonais ils sont
toujours plus de 4000 migrants déterminé
à passer la frontière
il est question de la crise migratoire
en europe qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre en france également les
critiques fusent notamment après le
démantèlement ce matin d'un camp de
migrants à grande synthe dans le nord
évacuation par les forces de l'ordre
d'un millier de personnes
majoritairement des kurdes sur demande
de gérald darmanin des familles avec des
enfants et des nourrissons étaient
transportés par cars pour être mis à
l'abri selon le ministre de l'intérieur
et le préfet du nord une opération qui
intervient sur fond de tensions entre
paris et londres autour de la question
migratoire tony et pitaro avec bilal
bouasone
les tensions entre la france et la
grande bretagne n'en finissent pas cette
fois ci ce sont les traverses et
illégale de la manche par des migrants
qui sème la discorde londres jugent
cette situation inacceptable
des critiques qui provoque la colère du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
nous n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir de
nos amis britanniques
ce sont nos alliés mais nous ne sommes
ni leurs collaborateurs ni leurs
supplétifs les passeurs qui organise des
réseaux qui touche beaucoup d'argent et
qui exploitent des femmes et des enfants
ce sont des passeurs qui très souvent
sont en grande bretagne le nombre de
traversées illégale de la manche a
atteint un record jeudi dernier avec au
total 1185 migrants ayant réussi à
atteindre le sol britannique selon le
ministère britannique de l'intérieur
pour boris johnson la france doit fermer
le passage ce que je dirai à nos amis
français c'est que si vous fermez les
portes du couloir d'un côté les gens ne
viendront pas dans le couloir de l'autre
côté vous voyez ce que je veux dire nous
devons fermer ce mouvement des plages
françaises vers le royaume uni si vous
voulez empêcher les gens de venir en
france pour venir au royaume-uni
la réplique de gérald darmanin s'est
voulue cinglante est tout aussi
démonstrative pourquoi les gens vont à
calais c'est pour aller en grande
bretagne et pourquoi ils vont en grande
bretagne parce que le marché du travail
autorise les personnes en situation
irrégulière à travailler si les
britanniques changer très fortement leur
législation
les gens ne seraient plus à calais et à
dunkerque donc c'est nous qui subissons
la politique britannique le porte parole
du premier ministre britannique a assuré
que le gouvernement de bori johnson
voulait travailler de manière
constructive à la recherche d'une
solution pour y parvenir le ministre
français de l'intérieur s'est entretenu
lundi soir avec son homologue
britannique pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions
et clermont au secrétaire général
association salam a assisté au
démantèlement aujourd'hui de ce
campement de migrants à grande synthe
c'est notre tes mains ce soit
bonsoir clair un minot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord dans quelles conditions se sont
déroulées ces évacuations du grand camp
du camp pardon de grande synthe
oui monsieur le préfet du nord est
extrêmement fier parce que tout s'est
déroulé dans le calme effectivement ça
s'est déroulé dans le calme c'est à dire
que ils ont fait monter les gens dans
les autobus sans coups de matraque e100
mitraillette dans le dos simplement les
gens savaient très bien qu'ils avaient
le choix entre monter dans les bus ou
monter dans un autre bus direction la
police dans ces cas là les gens montrent
très très beau métier dans l'autobus
qu'on leur propose pour une mise à
l'abri sachant que cette mise à l'abri
google n'est absolument pas une solution
parce que une mise à l'abri
il ne permet pas de demande d'asile
n'est pas une mise à l'abri mais gens
qui sont chez nous sont à 95% soit
dégoûté c'est à dire qu'ils ont été
refusées on leur a refusé le droit
d'asile
les pays scandinaves et à la fois ou en
alternative ils ont osé fameuse
empreinte dublin à dire qu'on a pris
leur empreinte quand ils sont en train
de voir dans un autre pays que la france
donc il me board qui s'appelle eurodac
et qui repère dans quel pays on a les
empreintes digitales et c'est là on est
renvoyé demander l'asile c'est revenir
des gens dans un centre d'accueil sans
relever ses empreintes dublin ça ne sert
absolument à rien pour
ça veut dire que quand le ministre de
l'intérieur parle de mise à l'abri c'est
un terme que vous réfutez vous en tant
qu'association tout à fait sain terme
que nous recrutons des futons parce que
de toutes façons ces gens là on en a qui
sont partis dans la région dans ma vie
sont partis loin à 17 heures j'ai noté
leur on a un appel du giro est dit que
des gens sont encore dans un autocar
après 17 heures partis ce matin ils ne
savent pas au niveau et l'autocar roule
et donc il ya des gens qu'on emmène très
loin et ne savent pas où ils ne savent
pas ce qu'ils vont devenir spécialement
ils sont acheminés
à don est ce qu'on sait où ils sont
acheminés
donc justement les producteurs de
l'autocar j'espère que c'est mais les
gens qui monte d'un mètre carré ce qui
doit partir de le savent pas et ça c'est
toujours comme ça quand on a des
évacuations qu'elle soit obligatoire ou
choisie se passe toujours sans que les
gens qui montent dans l'autocar sèche
alors qu'on sait c'est une amie on sait
aussi et c'est important de souligner
que quoi qu'il arrive ces migrants ne
sont pas satisfait mollahs béni puisque
leur cible finale étant quand même le
royaume uni est pas forcément une
demande d'asile en france
alors leur but là leur but et le royaume
uni parmi et ses jambes même à une
proportion qui certainement souhaite le
royaume uni parce qu illusion de la
famille parce que il parle parfaitement
anglais mais même des gens qui parlent
anglais même des gens qui ont une
famille souvent si on leur offrait une
situation en france avec des papiers et
le droit de travailler ensemble vous
croyez qu'on a envie de se mettre sur un
canot pneumatique qui va traverser la
manche comme ça en sachant qu on risque
sa vie à sa chambre mais ses enfants sur
l'eau et qu'ils risquent leur vie vous
croyez qu'on le fait de gaieté de coeur
parce qu'on a envie d'aller en
angleterre si ça avait une autre
solution s'ils étaient accueillis en
france
trois quarts de ces gens su persuader
les six avaient des papiers après qu'on
va aller voir leur famille en angleterre
s'il avait des papiers et l'autorisation
de travailler il pourrait faire une seat
se trouvait une situation en france
alors en angleterre en c'est en tout cas
la france est pointée du doigt pour son
traitement des migrants vaut aussi en
tant qu'association vous avez été témoin
de traitement inhumain de ces personnes
dans le nord de la france avait
complètement oublié c'est pas des gens
qui sont battus c'est pas des gens qui
sont matraqués qui reçoit rarement
reçoivent de gaz lacrymogène par contre
ils sont dans des camps
à leur prendre toutes leurs affaires or
as complètement le camp n'ont plus rien
les associations n'ont plus de tentes et
de bâches à distribuer demande là ce
soir à grande synthe ce qu'on va trouver
pour mettre à l'abri ceux qui ne sont
pas parties et il n'y a pas un sac a pas
de toilettes rien absolument pas une
cabine de toilette ya pas de douche il
ya des deux gymnases de dunkerque deux
fois dans la semaine offre une
possibilité à des associations de
d'encadrer les gens pour qu'ils prennent
une douche mais là ils sont devenus
tellement nombreux que les associatifs
qui peuvent le faire on dirait non plus
on peut plus il ya trop de monde qui
vient ou prendre une douche et on y
arrive on se souvient que c'est vraiment
qu'il s'agit on se souvient qu'en 2017
et autorités ne souhaitait pas à la
construction de d'accueil notamment de
deux gymnases parce qu'il craignait un
appel d'air notamment gérard collomb est
ce qu'aujourd'hui c'était un bon choix
ce que cela a changé quelque chose
rien du tout le l'appel d'air c'est pas
pas les conditions d'accueil quand on
voit les gens qui arrivent actuellement
le nombre de gens qui arrivent alors
qu'il fait mauvais effet alors qu'il
pleut alors que regarder vous avez
l'image alors qu'on leur enlève leur
tante que ils partent avec un tout petit
bagage
essentiel qu'ils vont revenir et qui
n'auront plus rien c'est pas l'accueil
pour la robe qui fait un appel d'air
c'est l'angleterre c'est ce set c'est ce
sentiment qui n'ont que ça comme
solution qu ailleurs comme en angleterre
et ne peuvent pas l'aider tout car ils
sont dégoûtés ils ont les empreintes
dublin et voit plus d'autre solution
mais on leur offre une autre solution et
y resteront ils seront contents de
rester et pour ça et à ce moment là
évidemment et des centres d'accueil qui
soit digne là c'est effrayant le manque
de dignité le manque d'humanité avec
lequel on reçoit ces gens merci beaucoup
plaire raynaud secrétaire général
l'association salam un d'avoir témoigné
en direct sur rt france ce soir
démantèlement du camp de grande synthe
au moment où un rapport donc sur les
migrations et publié en france un
document qui justement juste très
sévèrement l'action de l'état le
président de cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire sébastien nadeau était sur
notre plateau ce matin il ya une urgence
aller à calais la grande synthe elle est
à bien des endroits sur notre territoire
et pendant ce temps là on on continue de
monter un grand spectacle médiatique
sans s'occuper de ceux dont on a à
s'occuper parce qu'en france on a à
s'occuper des gens qui sont dans le
dénuement des gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
quand on parle de phénomène migratoire
on parle d'étrangers et quand on parle
d'étrangers moi je suis désolé mais vous
voyez qui parle des étrangers qui
parlait phénomène migratoire le ministre
de l'intérieur mais enfin le ministre de
l'intérieur il s'occupe de l'ordre
public et de l'insécurité en france
il ne sait pas il ne peut pas il n'a pas
la compétence pour comprendre les
phénomènes migratoires et les gens qui
sont dans ces services ne peuvent pas
intégrer un certain nombre de nécessité
par rapport à ce phénomène nous avons
affaire à des êtres humains avant
d'aboyer et puis dani mais je ne sais
quelle peur à leur sujet ces gens y
viennent ils ont des valeurs il existe
ils ont une existence ils ont un passé
il ya des gens très bien comment se
fait-il qu'on les considère comme des
animaux restrictions de l'octroi des
visas gestion policière de l'immigration
durcissement de l'accès des étrangers
aux soins dans son rapport la commission
d' enquête parlementaire sur les
migrations n'épargne donc pas le
gouvernement en ce début de campagne
présidentielle il faut dire que la
gestion des flux de migrants en flammes
la classe politique alors la france
montre tel exemple face à la crise
migratoire on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france et c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler pour ce face
à face donc laurent jacomelli porte
parole de marine le pen candidate fn à
la présidentielle bonsoir laurent
jacques aubé dit merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés thomas porte monde de la
direction de génération s vous étiez
aussi thomas porte en porte parle de
sandrine rousseau candidate à la
primaire europe ecologie les verts pour
la présidentielle en septembre dernier
bonsoir à vous et si merci d'être là on
a vu ce rapport parlementaire qui
épingle sévèrement la france traitements
inhumains comment expliquer ce constat
thomas porte est-ce qu'il ya des
dégradations des conditions des migrants
sur le territoire français avec ceux ce
gouvernement mais vous venez de donner
la parole à une représentante de
l'association qui a très bien décrit la
situation aujourd'hui on voit ce qui se
passe à calais où on a des femmes des
enfants et des hommes qui sont emmenés
dans des bus pour être déplacé on
détruit avec des couteaux leurs tentes
alors que c'est la seule chose dont ils
disposent on a aujourd'hui des bulldozer
qui sera menée contre les quins de ces
gens là qui n'ont rien d'autre je le
répète que leur tante et la france a été
condamnée est rappelé à l'ordre
plusieurs fois par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme pour le traitement
inhumaines et on se rappelle notamment
de la loisy l'émigration qui avait
allongé la durée de rétention des
mineurs dans des centres donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui la politique de la france
elle n'est pas à la hauteur et je crois
que la une qui avait fait à l'époque le
nouvel obs avec emmanuel macron entouré
de barbelés qui a fait scandale elle
témoigne aujourd'hui ce qu'est la
politique migratoire de la france elle
n'est pas la hauteur de ce qu'il
faudrait faire à la fois en france et en
europe laurent jacques aubé dit quand
vous entendez ces témoignages le rapport
on a entendu sébastien nadeau on a
entendu cette représentante de
l'association qu'est ce que vous
répondez alors qu'on sait que votre
parti est très en pointe évidemment sur
ce sujet je crois qu'il faut changer
radicalement de politique migratoire
aujourd'hui cette politique elle fait
que tout le monde perd les citoyens
français sont perdants parce que les
caisses d'allocations sociales se
creusent en faveur des migrants parce
que l'emploi reculé qu' il n'y a pas de
place pour tout le monde et que
l'insécurité augmente à cause notamment
d'une immigration incontrôlée de l'autre
côté on voit des pauvres gens qui
traversent le monde parfois sur des
canaux qui risquent leur vie tout
simplement parce qu'il croit un eldorado
qui n'est pas réel il n'ya plus d'emploi
au royaume uni mais
on le voit bien d'ailleurs que la
plupart sont des déboutés du droit
d'asile donc il faut faire respecter la
loi le droit d'asile aujourd'hui
largement détournée par un certain
nombre de migrants pour venir profiter
des largesses de la france parce que je
trouve le rapport un peu dur quand on a
les soins gratuits quand on a un migrant
clandestin quand on est hébergée quand
on est parfois même mieux traités que
certains français en matière de logement
bien tout cela n'est plus normal donc
tout le monde est perdant dans cette
affaire faisant respecter la loi quand
on n'a pas le droit d'être en france on
doit être ramené dans son pays d'origine
et puis la france doit maintenant
arrêter d'être dans une situation
paradoxale où puisqu'elle a les
frontières ouvertes tout le monde arrive
mais comme la frontière vers le royaume
uni est fermé tout le monde reste ces
gens ne veulent pas être en france il
n'y a plus de place en france une
solution qu'ils rentrent chez eux
thomas porte je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
alors de mon interview avec sept
représentants d'associations à l'époque
on s'en souvient après le démantèlement
de la jungle c'est en 2017 gérard
collomb avait refusé la construction
centre d'accueil parce qu'il ne voulait
surtout pas d'appel d'air
aujourd'hui clairement que fait-on de
ces personnes et est ce que c'était une
bonne stratégie à l'époque justement
dans la stratégie de gérard collomb elle
n'était pas bonne et les associations
l'avait déjà condamné à juste titre
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut pas
laisser ces milliers de gens qui
arrivent dans notre pays qui arrive dans
tous les pays d'europe en réalité parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des flux
migratoires qui sont aujourd'hui
important on peut pas parler de ça sans
parler du contexte aussi climatique dans
lequel sonné puisque on va en avoir dans
les années à venir au regard des crises
climatiques donc il faudra avoir moi je
crois un pacte de fraternité d'humanité
pour permettre à toutes ces femmes rang
mais enfin de les accueillir dignement
et moi je crois qu'on a les moyens de
les accueillir on est calme dans la
cinquième puissance économique mondiale
et on dit toujours il ya pas de travail
a pas de logement mais on a les moyens
de créer des emplois n'a les moyens de
construire de logements dont on a
aujourd'hui des mères qui refusent de
construire construisant pour accueillir
toutes ces personnes là pour permettre à
chacune et chacun de vivre dignement
c'est aujourd'hui un véritable enjeu si
on peut pas laisser je termine juste une
semaine on peut pas laisser des gens
dans des situations de tels qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui c'est absolument
inhumain la responsabilité de la france
elle n'est pas de laisser des gens
aujourd'hui dehors
la france joue son rôle d'abord il ya le
droit d'asile et ça je pense que
personne en tout cas eu ni vous ni moi
ne le remettons en cause quand quelqu'un
est persécuté dans son pays pour ses
opinions politiques par exemple la
france le droit d'asile et ça il faut
évidemment le maintenir parce que ce
sont des gens que nous devons accueillir
en revanche détourner le droit d'asile
pour venir de pays qui ne sont pas en
guerre où les gens ne sont pas
persécutés et venir en france toucher un
certain nombre de prestations sociales
là pour le coup ce n'est pas normal ce
n'est pas normal pour les français qui
se saignent aux quatre veines qui payent
des impôts et qui eux ont du mal parfois
à être aidée par la collectivité qui ont
du mal à trouver un logement alors que
des gens qui arrivent clandestinement
ses terres dans le premier acte de
violer la loi française eux sont soignés
gratuitement et logés je pense qu'il
faut retrouver un peu de raison les gens
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans certains
camps qui ressemble à des bidonvilles et
c'est très triste pour tout le monde
pour les voisins et pour ceux qui y
vivent eh bien ces gens là ne fuit pas
un problème climatique ne fuit pas la
guerre ils sont très souvent
majoritairement puisque 95% sont
déboutés du droit d'asile à calais le
taux national et deux tiers ils viennent
pour profiter des largesses sociale de
la france donc il faut arrêter ces
pompes aspirantes pour aider d'abord les
français aient effectivement ceux qui
ont le droit d'asile et que nous
continuerons accueillir bien sûr thomas
parmi ces recommandations le rapport
suggérait la création d'une agence
européenne de l'asile justement l'europe
parlons-en aucune politique vraiment
commune en matière d'intégration est ce
que c'est pas une grande majorité du
problème aujourd'hui de cette crispation
autour de cette crise migraineuse crois
que là la gestion des migrations et de
l'arrivée de ces personnes là il faut
une réponse évidemment européenne et
c'est ce que dit la gauche depuis des
années c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
prendre ce problème là pays par pays il
faut une réponse politique aux niveaux
européen et vous en avez parlé au début
de votre édition ce qui est en train de
se passer aujourd'hui aux frontières de
l'europe est absolument scandaleux est
ce qu'on va laisser aujourd'hui 1500
2000 2500 personnes mourir dans une
forêt une zone de non droit où même les
journalistes n'ont pas l'heur d'aller où
est ce qu'on va dire au regard de ce qui
se passe la première priorité c'est
d'accueillir ces gens il faut les
accueillir est-ce qu on accepte dans
quelques semaines de se regarder dans
une glace et de dire qu'on a laissé des
gens mourir parce qu'on ne veut pas
ouvrir ses frontières pour accueillir
3000 personnes qui ne menace la sécurité
de personnes il faut accueillir à
serrières il faut accueillir ces
personnes là d'abord on peut pas les
laisser mourir il ya des enjeux
géopolitiques derrière quand on pourra
reparler sans naïveté de ce qui se passe
avec le jeu entre la biélorussie la
pologne et la russie mais la priorité en
terme d' humanité c'est d'accueillir ces
gens j'ai souvent je regarde en même
temps que je vous parle c'est ces
réactions qui nous parviennent à celle
de bernard à l'instant tout dépend des
nouveaux arrivants s'ils viennent en
voulant découvrir le pays y vivre en
adoptant la plupart des codes de vie en
commun qui existent alors ça peut être
une réussite c'est évidemment souvent le
sujet qui fâche le sujet évidemment de
l'intégration walster cheval de bataille
des nations même d'assimilation quand on
vient en france on doit vivre comme un
français à rome vie projet comme un
romain mais les gens qu'on voyait à la
frontière vous avez raison souffrent du
froid probablement de ce1 et il faut une
aide humanitaire sur place en revanche
on voit aussi des scènes où ils
s'envoient des projectiles sur les
policiers polonais où ils sont
extrêmement agressif et quand on veut
passer une frontière de manière invasive
ça augure très mal de l'avenir est donc
là encore les polonais nous protège tous
et courage au peuple polonais aux
dirigeants polonais ne cédez rien
n'ouvrez pas la frontière c'est l'échec
de l'union européenne l'échec de frontex
frontex qui a vu son directeur convoqué
par les instances européennes parce
qu'il avait osé contrôlé quelques flux
migratoires cette europe de l'union
européenne elle veut toujours plus de
migrants à l'image de l'allemagne il se
trouve que les français veulent toujours
moins parce qu'ils l'ont bien compris et
puis très honnêtement on l'a déjà vécu
avec la route syrienne en 2015 des
apprentis djihadistes sont arrivés en
france ne pas contrôler les frontières
s'est laissé rentrer tout le monde et
n'importe qui y compris évidemment des
pauvres gens mais y compris parfois des
terroristes cette politique elle doit
cesser une frontière ça protège il faut
à nouveau contrôlé et choisir qui
arrivent chez nous tu m'apportes laurent
jacot mm le point si vous dire le doigt
sur justement cette petite
problématiques européennes et françaises
ces opinions publiques souvent ne
veulent pas de l'immigration notamment
en france il ya un sondage est
évidemment 41% des français à institut
csa pour ses news à 41% des personnes
interrogées qui se déclarent favorables
à l'idée de stopper totalement
l'immigration dans l'hexagone et de
l'autre côté sur la van der leyen qui
dit voilà ce mur nous on va certainement
pas payer pour qu'ils rappellent un peu
les et valeurs humanistes de l'europe
c'est là que le bât blesse vraiment mais
vous dites qu'il ya quatre français sur
dix donc il risque même si sur dix
qu'ils soient sont favorables ça ne se
prononcent pas et je crois que la
réponse elle peut pas être la
construction de murs et mur de la honte
et les flux migratoires ils se
déplaceront on peut construire des murs
et se mettre des barbelés par tous les
gens quand il fit à la fois le climat à
la fois les guerres les persécutions la
misère ils arriveront toujours à
dépasser ce que ce qu'on construit pour
pouvoir vivre parce que ces gens-là ils
demandent qu'une chose à survivre et moi
je pense qu'il ya pas d'invasion
aujourd'hui on parle de 3000 personnes à
la frontière de la pologne trois mille
personnes donc aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas accepter je le redis ici parce qu'on
n'a pas aujourd'hui la france et
emmanuel macron n'a pas de parole forte
sur ce sujet là il va prendre la
présidence de l'union européenne en
quelques semaines est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on est certaine est-ce que tu as accepté
qu'en 2020 de primer la campagne elle
elle impose des thèmes et on a besoin
d'avoir des responsables politiques
menées par leclerc est ce qu'en 2021 on
peut accepter que des femmes des enfants
et des enfants soient aujourd'hui livrés
dans des zones où il fait moins 5° et
vous avez évoqué des tensions mais
imaginons nous un instant la passe de
ces personnes là qui ont traversé la
moitié du monde et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans la nuit sans nourriture
dans le froid est menacé aujourd'hui
entre deux états qui instrumentalisent
la misère des gens pour des enjeux posés
ces douches mettez vous à la place d'un
français qui n'a pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de d'obtenir des soins
dentaires et qui voit que c'est pas la
faute des migrants d'origine et je vais
terminer et devoirs des migrants eux
bénéficier de l'aide médicale d'état et
avoir ses soins dentaires gratuits des
français qui n'ont plus accès au
logement social probablement parce qu'il
en a pas assez vous l'avez dit mais qui
voit des familles fraîchement arrivé
leur passer devant cette humanité votre
humanisme ils valent jusqu'à ces gens là
jusqu'à ces sdf français qui meurent de
froid dans la rue lance vous entend
malheureusement très peu or la france
aujourd'hui en termes de ressources en
termes d'emplois n'a plus les moyens
d'accueillir toute la misère du milieu
et illustration des difficultés à faire
face à l'immigration clandestine je vous
propose de faire un petit enfin très
long d'ailleurs assez loin des tours à
mayotte le département français qui ne
parvient pas justement réguler l'afflux
de migrants venus des comores et
notamment des femmes enceintes sur place
on retrouve ray le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir régis alors
pour limiter l'immigration
déjà comment les mahorais vivent t-il
cette situation migratoire
dans cette situation migratoire ici elle
est pas nouvelle ça fait plusieurs
dizaines d'années ça a commencé à peu
près dans les années 2000 ça s'est
accéléré en 2011 au moment de
l'acquisition du statut de département
de l'île de mayotte mais sur l'île de
mayotte vous savez environ un habitant
sur deux est un étranger vient des
comores où vient d'enjoindre à côté donc
c'est une situation voilà qui est
pénible pourquoi parce que c'est une île
qui est très petit elle fait 370
kilomètres carrés et sur cette île
théoriquement l'insee donne le chiffre
de 250 mille habitants mais en réalité
il faut probablement le x 2 il ya des
gens partout il ya des bidonvilles qui
ont été construits un peu partout dans
l'île et puis il ya une situation de
violence d'insécurité
permanente on a discuté nous avec des
gens qui ont vécu ici pendant 40 ans et
qui ont vu la situation se dégrader au
fur et à mesure de leur vie s'ils ne
veulent pas quitter leur île eux mais en
tout cas la situation est très
compliquée très très compliqué les
compliqué également aussi au niveau de
l'hôpital et de la maternité qu'il a la
plus grande maternité de france dans
cette maternité qui se trouvent très
tout près de l'endroit où je vous parle
aujourd'hui dans cet internaute et
environ deux tiers des naissances sont
de 2 par an et de comment de comoriens
de 2 donc cessons d illégaux qui
viennent accoucher en france donc mais
en réalité aujourd'hui le droit du sol
n'est plus automatique c'est cette
situation migratoire fait qu' il est
d'abord été limités limité à trois mois
et qu'aujourd'hui un projet de loi qui
sera examiné en janvier 2000 2022
propose d'étendre cette exemption du
droit du sol à un an pour des parents
ayant des enfants qui tient pour des
parents qui accouchent pour les mères
qui accouchent justement dans cet
internaute et merci le sommier grand
reporter rt france allez prenez soin de
vous parce que semble-t-il la situation
un peu complexe autour de vous en tout
cas merci d'avoir été en direct avec
nous laurent jacomelli est effectivement
pour limiter l'immigration un certain
politique de la métropole propose à
l'instar de mayotte de supprimer le
droit du sol c'est le cas notamment de
michel barnier 1 l'ancien négociateur du
bric six candidats lr
une obole tous les possibles voyez les
les convertis de fraîche date voilà
michel barnier veut mener une politique
européenne trop migration contre les
frontières se à une révélation à
quelques mois des élections
présidentielles les miracles existent
apparemment donc ça veut dire que vous
êtes tout à fait d'accord évidemment il
faut supprimer le droit du sol à mayotte
et en france il faut ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui à mayotte et il faut avoir
une pensée pour les mahorais qu'il faut
absolument aider c'est un département
français en leur droit on leur doit cela
parce que sinon c'est une assistante à
département en danger mais c'est la
france dans quelques années donc il est
temps de demander leur avis aux français
sur l'immigration marine le pen leur
propose un référendum parce qu'elle sera
élue parce que il faut qu'on va mettre
tout sur la table fin du droit du sol
fin du regroupement familial
expulsion des étrangers délinquants
contrôle des frontières priorités
nationales à l'emploi au logement et aux
allocations sociales tout cela doit être
décidé par les français à qui on n'a
jamais demandé leur avis et qui
subissent aujourd'hui toutes les
conséquences d'une immigration subie que
sont la sécurité la perte du pouvoir
d'achat le chômage et les problèmes de
logement et thomas porte ça vous fait
bondir quand vous entendez cette
suppression du droit du sol oui ça me
fait bondir puisqu'on va si on supprime
le droit du sol à mayotte on va faire
des territoires de seconde zone et je
crois que on ne peut pas détricoter
l'histoire de france comme ça et en
vérité là aussi vous parler de ce qui se
passe à mayotte mais il faut aussi
évoquer la situation de pauvreté parce
qu'on peut pas dénouer le contexte la
crise migratoire de ce qui se passe
là-bas 86 % des gens qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté une
personne sur trois qui vit dans un
logement n'y a pas de point d'eau donc
tout ça cristallise les tensions et on
peut pas simplement instrumentalisé est
montré du doigt l'immigration et dire
qu'ils sont responsables de la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat qui sont responsables de
la sécurité alors qu'on sait que c'est
absolument pas vrai et dans les
statistiques ethniques technique pardon
dans ce pays sont interdites donc il
faut aussi sifflé
et les migrants ne sont pas responsables
aujourd'hui de la danse et du fait que
les prisonniers sur quatre en france
aujourd'hui mais le soleil du mois erwan
le solde migratoire en france entre 2010
et 2019 l'institut national des études
démographiques l'a dit c'est 0.4 dont
1000 habitants ça vient de sortir 400
450 mille migrants enix nous faut ce
sujet vous savez tout le monde pour
aller vérifier 270 mille personnes qui
ont des papiers en règle plus les
mineurs isolés qui sont tolérés plus les
demandeurs de droit d'asile ça ce sont
les migrants légaux ou toléré vous avez
ensuite l'immigration illégale c'est à
dire que ça fait quand vous multipliez
par 5 des chiffres
il y à vraiment quand vous voyez le cas
dans certaines banlieues selon l'insee
relié par le 1er mai le cabinet du
premier ministre et bien 75 % des
enfants sont nés de parents étrangers ça
pose une question ça pose une question
de changement de population ça pose une
question du fait qu'aujourd'hui la
natalité est livré à l'immigration et
que nous devons reprendre ensemble les
rênes de notre civilisation de notre
culture ne pas importer la misère ne pas
importer d'autres lois et d'autres
moeurs et de préserver notre
civilisation c'est important vous savez
la culture les traditions les rations
thomas porte à la réponse parce que
j'allais vous dire beaucoup de ces
jeunes parler des banlieues beaucoup de
ces jeunes aussi sont français
aujourd'hui oui madame ils sont français
ils ont les papiers quand on voit
certains de ces français exhiber le
drapeau algérien par exemple agressé des
policiers comme ils hier où il ya deux
jours à lyon sale français de merde
excusez moi les propos mais contre un
policier qu'on agressait ils ne sont pas
français de coeur et même on peut
presque les considérait comme des
ennemis de l'intérieur ils détestent la
france alors vous en faites pas de ces
personnes voulaient renvoyés chez eux
alors qu'ils sont français sont le
français mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire s'ils sont français il faut
appliquer les peines s'ils commettent
des exactions il faut arrêter avec la
logique de l'excusent et puis surtout il
faut tarir le flux migratoire parce que
aujourd'hui la france n'assimile plus il
y a des générations d'immigrés qui sont
aujourd'hui français comme vous et moi
et qui sont très bien intégrés dans la
vie parce que et il y avait du travail
parce qu'ils ont été intégrés par
l'école le service militaire assimiler
ils revendiquent leur fierté d'être
français et ils sont arrivés légalement
et remercier la france de les avoir
accueillis or aujourd'hui on a des gens
qui viennent avec leurs habitudes leurs
moeurs leurs lois qui veulent nous les
imposer et qui déteste la france eh bien
ce sont deux immigration très différente
et je crois que la dernière il faut la
contrôler la tarière est l'une des
évidemment proposition qui tombent
souvent c'est celle que l'on sait aussi
nico en l'exemple sort est une
immigration choisie avec une vraie
intégration ce pas ce que fait la droite
par exemple il ya des décennies la
france a les mêmes chercher la main
d'oeuvre au maghreb avec campagne de
recrutement thomas porte ça cela vous
conviendrez une immigration choisie ou
là aussi c'est un gros mot non c'est un
gros mot et c'est on voit que une
instrumentalisation parce
qu'effectivement quand parle
d'immigration regarde toujours si
c'était un corps constitué et intègre
alors qu'il faudrait regarder les gens
dans leur individualité on se rend
compte que c'est des gens comme nous qui
vivent très bien dans ce pays qui
respectent les lois et d'ailleurs
l'insee dit qu'aujourd'hui on a à peu
près 10% immigrés sur le territoire donc
le grand emplacement il n'est pas du
tout à l'oeuvre mais vous parlais tout à
l'heure des violences sur les policiers
mais aussi on peut parler de ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours où des
révélations ont fait état de militants
d'extrême droite qui menace de mort des
gens donc il ne faut pas
instrumentaliser
sûrement dû doit montrer du doigt des
actes isolés pour stigmatiser une partie
de la population c'est pas acceptable je
pense que tous ceux qui vous regardent
aujourd'hui et qui vivent dans certaines
banlieues même des gens issus de
l'immigration et qui ne vivent plus en
tranquillité savent que ce que vous
dites est complètement déconnecté il y a
aujourd'hui en jeu en france des jeunes
qui déteste la france parce qu'on leur a
expliqué que nous avions a passé
colonial honteux parce que même le
président de la république d'ailleurs
les a chauffé à blanc en parlant de
crime contre l'humanité à propos de la
période d'algérie et donc ces jeunes là
qu'on a vu sur la peur jerry a pas eu
des crimes contre l'humanité
on vous rassure sur ce sujet merci en
tout cas tous les deux à l'orangé
comédie est thomas port d'avoir été avec
nous
et dans le reste de l'actualité le père
de julian assange devant l'assemblée
nationale à paris aujourd'hui il a
rencontré plusieurs députés des élus qui
appelle d'ailleurs la france a accordé
l'asile aux lanceurs d'alert
actuellement emprisonné au royaume-uni
l'on a présenté dans résolution les
précisions de notre reporter marième
laribi de jean-luc mélenchon à jean
lassalle en passant par cédric villani
jean christophe lagarde ou françois
ruffin ils sont une quarantaine de
députés français à porter ou à soutenir
ce projet de résolution au titre de
l'article 34 1 de la constitution pour
accorder l'asile à julian assange le
journaliste et fondateur de wikileaks
est détenu depuis deux ans et demi dans
une prison de haute sécurité à londres
après avoir passé sept ans
confiné et réfugié dans l'ambassade
d'équateur pour les députés français le
seul crime de julian assange et d'avoir
révélé la vérité sur les guerres
américaines au moyen-orient mais pour
eux également la france a une dette
envers julian assange on les écoute je
crois qu'il ya une prise de conscience
sur l'importance des documents qui ont
été révélés au monde entier par julian
assange
de l'influent si les antilles sur la
marche des affaires du monde et enfin et
peut-être
sur espère la face voudra rappeler
qu'elle a une voix universaliste et une
voix qui peut s'élever au-dessus des 1
sources de l'histoire il ya la liberté
de notre pays quelque part qui se
trouvait être espionnés par son allié
américain
sous trois présidents successifs jacques
chirac nicolas sarkozy françois hollande
révélée par julian assange services
rendus à la nation et donc oui je pense
que là il ya des motifs qui sont des
motifs différents qui peuvent se meut
les se mêler se cumulent et qui font que
des parlementaires le nom de tous
horizons différentes 10 on doit lui
accorder le droit d'asile julian assange
va pouvoir sortir de sa prison anglaise
échapper aux griffes américaine et venir
dans l'esprit de voltaire de se réfugier
dans le pays quoi cette conférence de
presse qui s'est tenue en présence du
père julian assange john shipton ainsi
que de sa compagne estelle à maurice qui
tous les deux ont exprimé un grand
espoir devant cette initiative des
parlementaires français on écoute le
père julian assange
[Musique]
on assiste ici à la naissance d'un
mouvement en france il y a 6 parlement
dans le monde qui ont composé des
groupes trans partisan pour assange
c'est le cas au bundestag votre voisin
ici en france la france bien sûr le
royaume uni la grèce en 1 l'italie en un
l'espagne aussi enfin l'australie en un
il ya donc un mouvement à travers le
monde qui se constituent pour que
justice pour que julian puisse rentrer à
la maison ce n'est pas grand chose juste
qu'il puisse rentrer à la maison
d'ici la mi-décembre la justice
britannique doit rendre son verdict sur
l'appel des etats-unis contre le refus
d'extradition de julian assange mais
quel que soit ce verdict la partie
perdante pourra toujours faire appel
devant la cour suprême du royaume uni ce
qui prolongera la détention de julian
assange son père et sa compagne dénonce
ses conditions de détention et alertes
sur son état de santé physique et
psychologique qui selon eux empire de
semaine en semaine
l'actualité politique en france avec la
fin aujourd'hui les adhésions chez les
républicains les ailes aaron gagné près
de 16 mille adhérents en un mois le
parti compte désormais plus de cent
trente deux mille cinq cents militants
encartés une base solide de votants pour
désigner le futur candidat à l'air à la
présidentielle c'est notre rubrique l
édito avec alexis poulain
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous
plus de 50000 adhésion en septembre ça
donc plutôt bien marché cette opération
ce qu'on peut parler d'un argument en
buvant populaire où on s'emballe un peu
ton badin je crois alors certes ça a
bien marché 50000 adhésion pour cinq
candidats ça fait dix mille par candidat
on voit que chaque camp a essayé de
recruter un maximum que ce soit en
savoie pour michel barnier en paca pour
eric ciotti en ile-de-france où il ya
beaucoup également d'adhésion pour
valérie pécresse et puis dans le nord
évidemment avec xavier bertrand là on
voit que tout le monde essaye de
récupérer notamment xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse qui avait quitté le
parti et qui essaye de séduire de
nouveaux arrivants qui vont voter parce
que chaque voix qui est maintenant
comptabilisé ceux qui payent pour voter
vont forcément voté ont déjà choisi
finalement leur champion ou leur
championne donc c'est extrêmement
important évidemment de savoir
engouement populaire on en est loin on
est loin bien sûr des 4 millions qui ont
voté à la primaire en 2017 pour françois
fillon donc là on est vraiment sur des
échelles qui ne sont pas les mêmes à tel
point que certains leaders de la droite
un critique et la cgt en disant qu'elle
n'avait aucun poids alors que la cgt à
600 mille adhérents là on est à 150
mille adhérents vous voyez que c'est
loin des chiffres passés pour les grands
partis
alexia ce concept déjà à qui peut
profiter cette à cet engouement vous
m'avez corriger mais voilà cette
association va dire
ben c'est tourtouse yasui il est des
gens qui veulent voter on a des
sympathisants de droite des électeurs de
droite qui veulent un champion une
championne de la droite qui veulent
quelqu'un qui va les représenter à cette
élection parce que on voit bien que ça
tire dans tous les côtés entre emmanuel
macron qui tire le tapis eric zemmour
qui arrive comme un chien dans un jeu de
quilles là pour ces nouveaux arrivants
ça va sans doute favoriser quelqu'un
comme xavier bertrand on valérie
pécresse qui avait quitté le parti et
qui se défend d'avoir voulu faire autre
chose qui dise voilà maintenant il faut
réunir la famille de droite ce que fait
d'ailleurs la droite et ce qui a du mal
à faire la gauche puisque à gauche c'est
l'hécatombe a disons que les les scores
dans les sondages des différents
candidats restent assez faibles et
certains voudraient faire l'union là à
droite au moins la consigne est claire
faisons une union autour d'un candidat
d'une candidate mais avec un débat
d'idées sens a aucune chance de se
retrouver au second tour alors encore
deux débats pour départager les
candidats que retenir des deux premières
réunions thématiques de l air une
appartient en recherche d'un valideur
peut-être pas clairement oui et on voit
que ils ont du mal à se démarquer les
uns des autres puisque il faut rassurer
les électeurs de droite et dire que
cette fois ci les républicains la droite
républicaine revient dans le jeu
politique en force parce que c'est un
parti qui a du mal à être dans
l'opposition et c'était des sujets
connus un des sujets habituels de la
droite la sécurité le pouvoir d'achat
l'immigration et là on a vu quelques
divisions comment c'est arrivé avec eric
yoth innombrables notamment qui a été le
premier à dire qu'il était prêt à voter
eric zemmour au second tour s'il fallait
le faire pour les autres il ya encore
une ligne rouge mais on voit bien qu'ils
sont gênés par rapport au programme d'
emmanuel macron par rapport à sa
politique y compris sanitaires xavier
bertrand comme valérie pécresse se
veulent aller encore plus loin à
l'encontre des non vaccinés continuer la
politique du pass thani terre sur
l'immigration tous sont à peu près
d'accord mais là encore emmanuel macron
tire le tapis sur la valeur travail lors
de son discours la semaine dernière il a
martelé plus d'une dizaine de fois le
mot travail et c'est long deux volets
aussi cette valeur totem de la droite
pour être le candidat finalement de la
droite même si il est plutôt du côté de
la droite centriste emmanuel macron on
voit bien que là c'est difficile de se
positionner pour les républiques à avec
en plus eric zemmour qui emmène tout le
monde à sa traîne vers un discours plus
radicalisés plus dur sur avec ce thème
du grand remplacement qui n'est pas
contestée par de nombreux candidats
de la droite et donc on a vu des débats
finalement
assez peu agitée on a l'impression que
tout le monde est en mode croisière
personne n'a envie finalement de sortir
la petite phrase de trop il ya l'épisode
montebourg qui a montré que finalement
l'outrance une fois qu'on a déclaré
candidat c'est plutôt se tirer une balle
dans le pied donc c'est des débats
extrêmement police essaie des débats qui
reste dans les clous qui vont permettre
à chacun de montrer quelques tendances
quelques nuances mais qui sont loin là
encore de faire sortir une tête du lot
merci alexis poulain d'avoir été avec
nous
et dans le reste de l'actualité
l'actualité notamment internationale les
américains qui accusent la russie
d'avoir tiré hier missiles
antisatellites un acte jugé
irresponsable par washington
condamnation également de l'otan n'en
parle avec thomas bonne et notre
correspondant aux états unis bonsoir
thomas selon washington donc ce tir a eu
pour conséquence de menacer la sécurité
des cosmonautes se trouvant dans la
station spatiale internationale
oui ça a été une réaction très rapide de
la part de washington réaction assez
virulente aussi puisque le porte-parole
de la diplomatie américaine dès ce lundi
a condamné cet essai mené par moscou net
price a notamment parlé de 1500 débris
orbitaux traçable provoquée par cet
essai il s'est donc inquiété de cette
menace pour les astronautes mais aussi
dit il une menace pour les intérêts de
toutes les nations je vous propose
d'écouter ses déclarations
en outre ce test augmentera
considérablement le risque pour les
astronautes et des cosmonautes de la
station spatiale internationale ainsi
que pour les autres activités de vol
spatial humain
le comportement dangereux et responsable
de la russie met en péril la viabilité à
long terme de l'espace extra
atmosphérique et démontre clairement que
les prétentions de la réussi à s'opposer
à la militarisation de l'espace sont
fallacieuses et hypocrite les etats-unis
travailleront avec leurs alliés et
partenaires pour répondre à l'acte
irresponsable de la russie
en effet également condamné par le
patron de la nasa ainsi que par le
secrétaire général de l'otan ce dernier
s'inquiète aussi de ca débris mais il
s'inquiète surtout du fait que la russie
développe des armes qui peuvent détruire
des satellites alors il convient de
rappeler qu'en décembre 2019 les
etats-unis ont créé officiellement une
sixième branche de leurs forces armées
une branche exclusivement consacrée à
l'espace un corps militaire qui est
dirigée par un général qui a lui aussi
réagi à cet essai russe faisant part lui
aussi de sa préoccupation il a parlé je
cite d'un comportement irresponsable de
la part de moscou qui constitue là
encore dit il un menu une menace à usage
pacifique de l'espace
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et du côté de moscou à on
admet aujourd'hui avoir pulvérisé un
satellite en orbite au cours de ce tiers
des ce et on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondante verra
dans la capitale russe cette fois verra
alors comment réagissent les autorités
russes après ces accusations
bonsoir stéphanie l'hypocrisie seul mot
utilisé par le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov pour qualifier la
réaction des états unis quant aux tirs
de missiles antisatellites russe le
ministre a également dénoncé
l'ambivalence des états unis au sujet de
la militarisation de l'espace je vous
propose d'écouter
affirmé que la russie est à l'origine de
risques qui pèserait sur l'utilisation
pacifique de l'espace relève pour le
moins de l'hypocrisie comme vous l'avez
justement remarquer il n'y a aucune
preuve de cela mais je vais vous donner
d'autres faits les etats-unis nous
appelle comme ils le disent à développer
des normes universelles pour
l'exploration spatiale mais depuis des
années qu'ils négligent l'initiative de
la russie et de la chine concernant la
préparation de l'accord sur la
prévention de la course aux armements
dans l'espace
il a négligent tout simplement en
insistant sur l'établissement des normes
de conduite
néanmoins les etats-unis eux-mêmes
développe cette course aux armements
très activement
le ministère russe de la défense a
également réagi aux déclarations
américaines en profitant la possibilité
d'une menace créée à la station spatiale
internationale et les cosmonautes
écouter
en 2020 les états unis ont créé le space
com end et ont adopté officiellement une
nouvelle stratégie spatiale dont l'un
des principaux objectifs est de créer un
avantage militaire globale dans l'espace
à son tour le pentagone avant même ces
mesures officielles et encore plus après
développe activement et s en orbite sans
aucune notification ses dernières armes
d'attac et de combats de divers types y
compris les dernières versions de la
navette spatiale sans pilote x 37 les
actions de la partie américaine sont
considérés comme une menace et sont
incompatibles avec les objectifs
déclarés d'utilisation pacifique de
l'espace ministre russe de la défense a
admis donc avoir détruit ce lundi un
satellite oui en affirmant que les
activités que la russie mène dans
l'espace sont planifiés et vise à
renforcer sa capacité de défense et les
autorités russes ont également appelé à
mettre en place des normes universelles
de l'exploration spatiale pour la
communauté internationale merci beaucoup
verhaeghe hoffman en direct de moscou
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
ou parlement de la situation sanitaire
en france quelle arme utilisée pour
faire face à une éventuelle cinquième
vague de contamination elle nous serons
avec stéphane froguel généticien
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant en coule et où ça n'a
plus rien fait pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont le désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme si
son travail en notre nom pour nous est
dans notre intérêt à tous
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pg légende
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
nouvelle hausse de 12,6 pour cent pour
les prix du gaz au 1er octobre du côté
des carburants ce n'est pas mieux qu'à
part redonner un peu de marge pour
pouvoir d'achat l'exécutif est
complètement impuissant non l'état il
vous fait pas cadeau l'état c'est nous
donc on se fait des cadeaux à nous mêmes
le problème c'est que ça ne résout pas
le problème c'est le décale il faut
qu'il fasse quelque chose de visible et
baisser une taxe n'est pas visible en
revanche vous envoyez un chèque ces
visites c'est pas quand les matières
premières explosent à la hausse qu'il
faut se poser la question c'est avant
tout gouverner c'est prévoir mais c'est
pas seulement prévoir sa réélection
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts
nés sur la bbc une surveillance des
hopitalisés il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de moi même toute
cette histoire est donc ça m'a apporté
un peu de recul un peu d'apaisement mais
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre non deux singes
le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descends du
sage moi sûrement pas révélé nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du man où je
me trouvais à fouiller en sibérie et
puis un bon matin dans le trou que
j'avais commencé à creuser je trouve de
lait tout comme celle quelque chose de
bien des grands filaments je suis à
donner je râle je dirais que ce sont des
collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre est une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé il
a toujours existé la première grande
manifestation parisienne du 6 février 34
on a même pu craindre la disparition de
la toute jeune garde républicaine billes
dans la presse s'était déchaînée sur ce
qu'était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
l'adn de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible puis deux années même avec
monsieur alpha condé deux pays étaient
dans une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire quelle arme utilisée pour faire
face à une éventuelle cinquième vague de
contamination de kobe 19 en france pour
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement ont qu un confinement
prévue aujourd'hui ni de près ni de loin
pourtant les hospitalisations sont en
hausse d'un peu plus de 6 % et le taux
d'incidence augmente au dessus de 100
cas pour 100000 habitants
[Musique]
confinement strict ou allégées
couvre-feu pas sanitaires pour lutter
contre le coc vis de la france donc mis
en place plusieurs mesures en bientôt
deux ans depuis lundi l'autriche ccl au
confinement des seuls non vaccinés pour
l'heure la situation sanitaire dans
l'hexagone permet d'écarter toute
nouvelle restriction mais que peut-il se
passer en cas d'aggravation éléments de
réponse avec nadège ad razak avant de
retrouver notre invité tout à l'heure
pour en parler il ne faut jamais dire
jamais l'adage est d'autant plus de
circonstance que depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire le gouvernement a dit
tout à fait tout et son contraire masque
pas sanitaire obligations fax inhalent
pour certaines professions tout ceci a
fini par être exigé alors un confinement
des français non vaccinés à l'image de
ce qui se passe en autriche c'est l'un
des scénarios qu envisage sérieusement
certains candidats à l'investiture des
républicains s'y lie à une recrudescence
de la pandémie qui mettent en danger des
vies je ne leur confie dre pas tous les
français les français qui se sont fait
vacciner ont pris leurs responsabilités
j'envisagerai leur confinement
uniquement des non vaccinés s'il ya des
décisions difficiles à prendre je les
prendrai à l'égard des non vaccinés
l'exécutif de son côté se montre moins
catégorique
pourquoi d'abord parce que depuis
juillet fut une partie de la population
se mobilise déjà chaque samedi contre le
passé ni terre imposer un confinement
aussi millions de français non vaccinés
ne ferait que mettre de l'huile sur le
feu et à cinq mois de l'élection
présidentielle
ce n'est pas forcément bon calcul nous
ne le souhaitons pas et nous devons tout
faire pour empêcher que nous ayons
besoin d'aggraver les moyens de
protection des français l'objectif est
la méthode que nous avons tenu c'est
celle de la vaccination et du rappel la
france n'est pas à l'abri d'une nouvelle
vague alors que la france compte plus de
51 millions de primo vacciner comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi gabriélat
talent le porte parole du gouvernement
continue d'appeler les français à se
faire vacciner et revacciner la
cinquième vague sera celle des non
vaccinés et des personnes fragiles non
rappeler chaque injection éloignent un
patient de l'hôpital et nous rapproche
collectivement d'un hiver serein
d'un point de vue juridique l'exécutif
peut-il décrété un confinement pour les
seules personnes non vaccinées pas
vraiment l'état de droit ne le permet
pas d'autant que cette possibilité ne
figure pas dans les termes de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sous lequel le px
n'est même plus placé actuellement il a
en effet été remplacée par une période
transitoire de sortie de l'état
d'urgence je ne pense pas que l'on
puisse prendre des mesures différenciés
en fonction du statut vaccinal car la
seule différenciation que permet l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et territoriales il
ya une vraie question démocratique et de
cohésion sociale avec ce type de mesure
augmenter les contraintes sur la
population qui refusent le vaccin serait
susceptible de la radicaliser sans pour
autant parvenir à la faire changer
d'avis d'un point de vue constitutionnel
il semble difficile d'imposer des
contraintes aux seuls non vaccinés le
conseil constitutionnel pourrait en
effet retoqué cette décision sur la base
d'une rupture d'égalité des citoyens
devant la loi l'article 6 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 stipule que la loi doit
être la même pour tous et ce qu'elles
protègent ou bien qu'elle punisse
déclaration sur laquelle s'est assis
malgré tout plus d'une fois le
gouvernement ces dernières années
notamment en interdisant plusieurs
manifestations de gilet jaune et pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial college de londres et à
l'université lille 2 bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
un nombre de cas positifs au bic a bondi
de 30% en une semaine même s'il reste
plutôt à des niveaux raisonnables en
france selon vous philippe froguel la
france va rester épargnée justement par
les très mauvais chiffres que
connaissent certains voisins européens
on a à peu près la même augmentation
qu'ailleurs mais on part de beaucoup
plus bas et on peut espérer qu'avec les
mesures qui sont prises aujourd'hui que
on atteigne pas les niveaux absolument
énorme qu'on a actuellement en allemagne
avec c'est surtout ce nombre de morts
extrêmement important puisqu'il ya plus
de morts aujourd'hui en allemane qu'il y
en a en angleterre comment justement
vous expliquer cette situation et 7 on
va dire à quel me française en tout cas
sûr sur le plan des décès à l'hôpital
leurs enfants sont là deux choses qui se
sont complétés la première à une
vaccination qui s'est accélérée pendant
l'été
avec comme on l'a dit 51 millions de
personnes qui sont vaccinées il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui qu'une environ une
dizaine 12 m 2 pour cent de la
population qui n'est pas vaccinée pour
différentes raisons d'ailleurs et
d'autre part avec le pass qui les
parages vaccinale nommait impasse
sanitaires eh bien on a une limite et
d'une certaine façon à la circulation du
virus et donc les deux à la fois
ont permis d'avoir cette situation quand
même bien meilleure que dans beaucoup de
pays européens il est il normal je vais
dire une augmentation à l'image de ce
qui se passe ailleurs même si on part de
plus bas comment l'expliqué aujourd'hui
c'est l'immunité qui baisse
d'abord il y à l'hiver
qui est important c'est à dire que les
personnes vivent dans l'intérieur et ce
virus delta est très très très
contagieux moi ce que j'ai noté aussi
totalement métro que c'est commence à y
avoir des gens qui portaient plus le
masque et donc les mesures dites de
mitigation c'est à dire en fait
d'essayer de reculer à l'infection sont
un petit peu moins suivie qu'elle était
il ya trois mois et puis à tout ce qui
vient de l'étranger les frontières sont
pas fermées et elle notamment
d'allemagne d'angleterre et donc c'est
mécanique finalement ça va augmenter en
france pour l'instant ça n'a pas
énormément augmenté dans les hôpitaux et
et encore moins aux mortalités vous qui
justement connaissait bien l'angleterre
puisque vous y travaillez également à ce
que vous pensez qu'on est peut-être un
peu trop laxistes on sent de leur
enfance quand on va au royaume uni il
faut se tester au bout du deuxième jour
ce n'est pas le cas en france on non
uniquement impasse sanitaire est ce que
ça suffit aujourd'hui
en angleterre il ya eu beaucoup de cas
parce que gouvernement de boris johnson
à relâcher toutes ces mesures barrières
tombent dans le métro anglais il ya
peut-être 20 % des gens et surtout des
touristes tu portes qui porte le masque
est par contre ce qu'ils ont fait et ce
qui est pas mal c'est qu'il s'en aller
chercher les gens chez eux
ceux qui n'étaient pas vaccinés et c'est
ce qu'ont fait pas en france et ils ont
aussi bien augmenter le taux de
troisièmes noces chez des gens fragiles
ce qui fait que le ya peu près
aujourd'hui à 35 milles à 40 mille cas
par jour en angleterre mais l'ombre de
dix morts elle est assez stable mais il
est quand même trois fois plus élevés
qu'en france philippe froguel en france
sont est peut-être beaucoup moins est-ce
que désormais les tests en majorité
payant 1
ceci explique peut-être cela qu'on ne
teste pas donc on isole - par par
définition alors en france en tête un
peu moins maintenant depuis que l'été
sont payants mais on est peut-être mal
c'est-à-dire en angleterre tous les
toutes les familles reçoit des autotests
pour leurs enfants et on leur demande
très fortement de tester eux-mêmes la à
leurs enfants et puis n'importe qui je
veux dire mes enfants qui sont des
adultes et à une quête à ce mythique et
bien elle reçoit cinq tests par semaine
par la poste quelle qu'elle fait elle
même en france ces autos tests sont très
peu fait son lit centre quand une femme
est très peu fait et je ne suis pas sûr
que honte est obligatoirement les
personnes les plus à risque en tout cas
celles qui ont les premiers symptômes et
et qui devrait se tester et même d'abord
avant d'aller
dans un laboratoire art aujourd'hui
renaud muselier qui militait pour le
pass vaccinale a fait cette sortie il a
qualifié les non-vaccinés de bombes
virale est ce que vous vous partagez le
le même diagnostic
c'est toujours trop compliqué
[Musique]
pour des hommes politiques que dire les
choses clairement et je dirais de
manière propre
le vaccin n'empêche pas de se faire
infecter par parti
marginal mais existante des personnes
qui ont été vaccinées et une fois qu'ils
sont infectés sont autant de bombes et
une bombe infectieuses que ceux qui sont
ils ne sont pas vaccinés donc tous à
dire des approximations des choses
pareilles ne font que renforcer
la suspicion
non non on peut être être vaccinés être
infectés une fois qu'on a été bons on
peut transmettre vacciner ou pas de la
même façon que les non vaccinés philippe
froguel sauf erreur de ma part c'est
pourtant ce qu'on a on a souvent lille
contre lui le contraire que quand on est
vaccinés on transmet beaucoup moins je
connais plus le chiffre exact mais enfin
là vous venez j'avoue de m'apprendre
quelque chose ça veut dire que quand on
est vaccinés on transmet autant le virus
aussi on l'a alors les études sont très
contradictoires
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
les premiers jours ça ressemble aux non
vaccinés et il ya un certain nombre
d'études qui disent que ça s'arrête plus
rapidement chez les vaccinés que je suis
bon rythme et donc
c'est certes une bombe et c'est pas une
bombe à retardement qui sautent qui se
répète c'est
disons que le risque à long terme 15
jours ou une semaine et plus faible au
babc le manche et des vaccins dernière
question puisqu'on parle évidemment
beaucoup de l'autriche il ya eu ce débat
en français ce que le gouvernement ira
jusque là en tout cas certains candidats
notamment du côté des élèves mederi
pécresse ou xavier bertrand le demande
de confiner les non-vaccinés qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire vous
son plan politique ce que la course à
l'échalote est celui qui forme puisque
l'autre candidat la réalité c'est que
sont les 10-12 % de personnes non
vaccinées et on a la moitié qui sont des
personnes âgées des pains en ehpad et
qui sont très isolés et si on veut les
vacciner pour les chez eux chez elle et
les joindre directement ce pour n'a pas
fait du tout en france et puis il ya 5 %
d'irréductibles et ce n'est pas en les
confinant qu' il y aura une efficacité
tellement importante dans moi je ne
pense pas vraiment que ce confinement a
réservé aux non vaccinés servent à
quelque chose c'est plus sûr c'est plus
quelque chose pour
impressionner autrichien qui ne se sont
pas assez précipités vers les centres de
vaccination
merci beaucoup philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et l
université lille 2 merci à vous d'avoir
été en direct et la crise sanitaire
toujours avec une polémique 1 depuis ce
week-end l'an dernier seulement deux
ports sont d hospitalisation était liée
aux qu'ovide en france et le chiffre
choc m'a rapport officiel publié cette
semaine qui fait beaucoup réagir
et pourtant ce chiffre de 2% on ne rend
pas compte à lui seul de la situation
spital hier durant la pandémie les
explications nécessaires de guillemard
aussi alors on va couper tout de suite
court aux suspicions oui ce chiffre de 2
% est parfaitement exact il nous vient
d'un rapport de la tei h l'agencé
technique de l'information sur
l'hospitalisation qui a pour mission de
collecter et analyser les données
relatives aux établissements de santé
c'est un peu l'insee de l'hôpital si
vous préférez donc oui en effet en 2020
les personnes atteintes de kobe de 19
ont représenté seulement 2% de
l'ensemble des patients hospitalisés et
maintenant qu'on a dit ça en réalité
vers n'a pas dit grand chose en fait il
faut aussi regarder tout un tas d'autres
chiffres premièrement en 2020 les
français ont continué d'avoir des
cancers des avc des arrêts cardiaques
des appendicites des fractures et des
enfants aussi il n'y a donc pas eu que
le coc vide en revanche les infections
et à l'inflammation respiratoires comme
cause d'hospitalisation ont bel et bien
exploser en 2020 plus 412% c'est à dire
une multiplication par 4 c'était la 94e
cause d'hospitalisation en 2019 la
septième en 2020 et ce fameux chiffre de
2% il ne renvoie qu'à un nombre de
patients sauf qu'il faut aussi compter
avec la durée du séjour à l'hôpital le
nombre de jours de soins que requiert le
patient est justement les malades ducobu
vides ont été hospitalisés en moyenne
plus de 13 jours c'est plus de deux fois
plus long que la moyenne des
hospitalisations en 2019 des séjours
plus longs et donc qui pèse plus sur le
système de santé et c'est encore plus
flagrant pour les soins intensifs en
2020 un jour de prise en charge en
service de réanimation sur cinq étaient
dues aux qu'ovide plus de 10 %
d'activité en plus pour les service de
réa par rapport à l'année précédente et
tous ces chiffres dont on parle ce sont
des statistiques sur l'ensemble de 2020
un lycée sur toute l'année alors que le
coe vie de 10 9 a frappé par vagues
surtout au printemps et à l'automne
c'est un peu comme si pour parler du
temps qu'il a fait hier on se contentait
de dire que la température moyenne
annuelle en france était de 15 degrés ça
n'a pas vraiment de sens pour le coc vie
de ce qu'il faut regarder c'est le
nombre de patients par mois et surtout
le poids qu'ils font peser sur le
système de santé à un moment tu es en
fonction de la durée de leur
hospitalisation et malheureusement la
tei h n'a pas publié de données aussi
précises maintenant tout ce que je viens
de vous dire ça ne constitue pas un
argument en faveur de la politique
sanitaire gouvernementale je ne vous dis
pas que les confinements les couvre-feux
les fermetures de commerces ont été des
mesures proportionnées ni même
nécessaire et encore moins que le pass
sanitaire où l'état d'urgence sont
justifiées ce n'est pas le propos ici je
vous dis simplement que ce chiffre de 2%
que l'on entend partout ne permet
clairement pas à lui seul d'émettre un
jugement éclairé
mais en allemagne les quatre
contamination comme ils ont explosé ces
derniers jours à berlin dessinons de
renforcer les restrictions sanitaires
parmi les nouvelles mesures
l'interdiction d'accès à certains lieux
publics aux personnes non vaccinées des
tests pcr sont également obligatoires
pour rentrer dans les centres de
résidences pour personnes âgées d'autres
mesures doivent être discuté jeudi comme
une obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions réaction des berlinois à ces
annonces
sa manière même si quelqu'un est vacciné
il peut toujours être infecté par ce
virus est tombé malade je ne sais donc
pas vraiment si cela a un sens le mieux
serait d'avoir des restrictions un
détachement et demi
je trouve cela plutôt bien je suis moi
même vacciné et c'est pourquoi quand je
serai en intérieur je me sentirai
beaucoup mieux s'il ya des règles de g
même si on se fait tester on ne veut pas
être sûr de ne pas avoir le coronavirus
bien sûr vous pouvez le transmettre même
si vous êtes vacciné mais la probabilité
est beaucoup plus faible donc je pense
honnêtement que c'est mieux et que c'est
une bonne décision
compte tenu de l'augmentation des
chiffres je trouve cela raisonnable
mais je peux aussi comprendre les gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés moi même je
suis vacciné donc c'est bien pour moi
mais ce sera encore mieux s'il y avait à
nouveau des tests gratuits ça
faciliterait certaines choses et les
gens se ferait probablement tester plus
souvent
nous la font il sera l autorise la
vaccination des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
dans l'espoir de juguler la pandémie la
vaccination concernait jusque là les
mineurs de 12 à 17 ans les enfants de 5
à 11 ans bénéficieront du vexin présent
biotech la date du début de cette
nouvelle campagne vaccinale sera annoncé
dans les prochains jours pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis tel aviv
avec un pôle à slayer journalistes rt
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir paula merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les autorités qui
avaient donc commencer à vacciner on
rappelle les adolescents de 12 à 17 ans
mais là elles ont décidé d'abaisser
encore un peu plus cet âge à cinq ans
deuxième pays donc un prêt les états
unis pour quelles raisons
c'est bon le bois
mais collecter de vaccination contre le
virus c'est un sanglier et a décidé que
les avantages sont plus importants et
besoin que les risques 73 membres ont
voté en faveur de la vaccination 2
contres lors d'un vote à bulletins
secrets
à mener des études sur les groupes d'âge
des jeunes enfants et ces études ont
montré un taux d'efficacité de
97% il faut des gazons de savoir que les
enfants reçoivent un tiers de la dose
pour les adultes paula comment
réagissent les parents sur place parce
qu'on sait que c'est un débat qui est
pas toujours évident chez les adultes
mais peut-être encore davantage chez
chez les enfants est ce que ses parents
sont inquiets est-ce qu'ils ont
suffisamment de retours sur ce vaccin
[Applaudissements]
martelly était le père de 80 des enfants
il a déclaré que son enfant ne peut
jamais y serez d'accéder à inciter la
population à suivre son exemple un
expert du gouvernement sur yellow
coronavirus a déclaré que plus de 50 %
des israéliens en général soutenez la
vaccination des enfants
cela est largement dû au fait qu après
la vaccination les enfants n'avaient pas
besoin de refuser l'inscription de
recevoir détecte un petit génie qui
peuvent être particulièrement invasif
par les jeunes enfants
l'université de bar ilan à ces la ville
a publié le résultat d'une étude
dans le cadre de laquelle ils ont
interrogé 894 parents d'enfants entre 5
et 11 ans 57% de ses parents interrogés
et sec en faveur de la vaccination des
gens y font
cependant doussain en aide de la
communauté israélienne ultra orthodoxes
il y a une certaine avec 1500 les ce
problème se posait déjà pour la
vaccination en général donc cela je
change pas lorsqu'il s'agit des enfants
ultra-orthodoxes alors ou trois
évidemment la réalité de de tomber
malade et de contaminer les autres il ya
aussi en france on a connu la même chose
la baisse du nombre de fermetures de
classes il y a eu beaucoup justement de
fermetures de classes en israël
des
trois grands de toutes les écoles entre
mars 2020 et
2021 le début de l'année scolaire
actuelle
de l'année scolaire le premier ministre
israélien à staline est approuvée les
tests sérologiques que pour les niveaux
environ 200 m2 à 6e les places doivent
fermer et qu'un enfant aucun parent et
testé positif
le mois dernier de nouvelles conditions
ont été présentés pour les classes pour
ainsi dire merci
un des enfants et testé positif avec un
peu tous ses camarades
doivent prendre un test pcr tout si le
test est négatif il peut être revenir le
lendemain à l'école tout en maintenant
les distances de c'est que les distances
si tu étais avec les enfants des autres
classes puis sept jours plus tard ils
reçoivent un petit geste puis un test
pcr
davantage de ce système est que des
enfants ne doivent pas s'isoler un pôle
à une dernière question un peu plus
globale à pour pour terminer on l'entend
le voit il serait elle qui a été un
laboratoire pour le monde entier qui
prend des mesures quand même assez
significative assez importante
aujourd'hui quel est le le recul est ce
que la situation sanitaire en israël est
satisfaisante et s'en sort mieux que le
reste du monde dans sa globalité
[Applaudissements]
mont blanc
il a juste en dessous de 6000 heures de
conversation en israël le ministre de la
santé a déclaré que le faisait avec
surmonter ça casse
9,4 millions de personnes ont reçu leur
part diane doses de vaccins leur appel
cela représente deux tiers de la
population
les premiers inscrits et le ministre de
la santé et les semis un accord selon
lequel il n'y aura pas de restriction
pour les larges rassemblements
meriem de doses ont été administrées 16
millions de doses ils s'étaient
enregistrés et ils l'ont pourrait
parvenir jusqu'à un taux de vaccination
de 88 % à l'échelle du pays
des raisons majeures du soutien pour la
vaccination en israël c'est que les
autres obtenir des passeports gère ou
parce maximale en israël si jean n'a pas
reçu trois doses de vaccin voici mon
gens qui ne savent pas être recevoir des
dons de pfizer de l'internât qui sont
les accents les plus populaires en
israël se tourner vers astrazeneca
merci beaucoup place ailleurs ajourné
une certaine internationale en direct de
tda ville d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous exposer donc cette situation en
israël est la vaccination notamment des
plus petits et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain à 20 heures d'ici là
n'oubliez pas de respirer de commenter
sur les réseaux sociaux sur notre honte
et d g darty france en attendant
l'actualité continue toute la soirée
[Musique]
oui
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la sdb sinistralité hopitalisés il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait les bras on
a vu des personnes gravement blessées on
a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]